what's going on guys this is rob and i
done goofed
i misread joker volume two uh so it's
issues six through nine which we're
basically caught up except for issue
nine so we're going to do this one and
then once volume three completes we'll
do that there is technically an annual
that goes into it but there's no real
significance in terms of what's going on
here but in the last video that we did
we basically covered the origin of
bane's daughter right her whole story
how she came into existence that she was
basically created uh using the mental
patterns and the venom formula and then
some of the biology of bane but it's not
like bane banged a chick and then now we
have vengeance but it doesn't really
work that way um instead what this does
or at least what this particular video
does is we open up here essentially with
jim gordon telling his story to
vengeance which is the name of bane's
daughter i could have thought of a
better name but you know that's the name
of bame's daughter so the cool thing
about this is he really referenced it as
it being like the joker story and this
is kind of james tenyon hitting at the
idea of the killing joke right it's like
the joker story and the reason why is
for those of you guys who don't know the
killing joke is the definitive joker
origin it is well it's definitive
insofar as the one that fans recognize
as being the definitive origin dc's
never really come out and said this is
the definitive origin of the joker if
you ever want to know where the joker
came from go read that story and a lot
of that's because dc comics likes to
leave it ambiguous because usually
whenever they release a comic where it's
like the new origin of the joker it
always sells and so it's better to kind
of keep that thing alive as opposed to
cutting themselves off at the knees and
everybody just sort of referencing like
no don't read that story this one over
here is the one that you want to read
because it's official and so as a result
of this it's really more like a fan
adopted origin having said that it makes
sense right the killing joke is the
joker story i mean for the most part
like you walk up to anybody who's
familiar with dc comics and you say like
does the joker have an origin they'll
say not officially but go read the
killing joke it's the closest we get
right it's the one that everybody
references and so jim gordon telling
vengeance this story is based off the
idea that in the last video that we did
that while while vengeance was
engineered to want to kill the joker she
has this desire to do it because it was
programmed in her and so if she's going
to kill the joker she doesn't want to do
it because she was told to she wants to
do it because she wants somebody else's
motivation and so that's why jim gordon
basically tells the story that the joker
had shown up on his doorstep and shot
barbara gordon uh through the the
stomach which of course damaged her
spine and she was paralyzed for quite
some time now that of course led into
the first real introduction of barbara
gordon becoming oracle which is a great
concept for a character of course she
ended up having her back healed by lucas
fox and that in turn allowed her to go
through and uh become batgirl again
right to operate but of course when that
happened that jim gordon was basically
taken by the joker brought to this
sadistic theme park and so and like
forced to go through like this just
hellish roller coaster to experience
like all these images and all these
videos of his daughter basically being
brutalized by the joker's henchmen and
what he talks about are all these
experiences with a joker in some form or
fashion has screwed up his life but it's
not even really just the joker like it's
just gotham city itself that it's a
twisted in a screwed up place and he
even talks about james gordon jr now the
thing about james gordon jr this is one
thing to know is that at the moment he's
a
technically dead and and we believe that
he's dead he really came back during the
batgirl comics and what we ended up
finding out is that like there was
somebody going around uh almost in a
kind of jack the ripper fashion where
they were like killing different women
and james gordon jr was trying to figure
out who it was only to find out that his
psyche had basically split that there
was the good guy who was trying to
protect barbara gordon and trying to
keep his family safe and then the bad
guy who was the one doing the killing so
he was quite literally his own worst
enemy uh but nonetheless it's all these
different things that kind of feed in
together and give us this idea that like
gotham city itself is a pretty rough
place and so ultimately once you end up
getting uh vengeance and jim gordon
heading towards the home of what is
basically the head lab technician that
of course they knew the joker was gonna
go after once they get inside we
actually end up transitioning over to
barbara and to julia now again julia of
course being the daughter of alfred
pennyworth uh the one-time girlfriend
for a little while i guess maybe of of
kate kane right of batwoman but her and
barbara gordon working together are
really them just trying to figure out
what's going on because in the middle of
them looking into things they were
suddenly attacked by a talent the town
of course being one of the henchmen of
the court of owls and so this is kind of
their little little side story which
will actually become important later on
ah but it's a little bit of their side
story kind of focusing on the other side
of the equation where you have jim
gordon and you've got vengeance dealing
with the joker and all that kind of
stuff and so what this does as they're
sort of looking through things that in
these different investigations and
whatnot they of course give us a bit of
a recap on the uh on the development of
venom that venom was originally created
by a scientist named randolph porter
that it was designed to be a really
addictive version of the miraculous
formula now for those of you guys who
don't know we were never really given
this origin during the events of the
venezuelan storyline as part of
nightfall instead this actually came
from legends of the dark knight now for
those guys who don't know what legends
of the dark knight is that's a concept
in dc comics that started out great and
ended terribly so legends of the dark
knight followed up batman year one by
frank miller and where batman year one
was like here is basically batman's
first year as batman
that the legends of the dark knight
filled in the gaps and it showed us a
lot of the things that batman was doing
in the very early days it was phenomenal
when it first started by the end it was
just it was literally just a dumping
ground for like stories that had to do
with batman but just weren't very good
um or it was a test bed but it was a
place for people who were looking to get
their shoe in the door as like writers
or artists at dc comics where they would
just be thrown on lead into the dark
knight to see how they write how they
draw to see whether or not it performs
or or has any real benefit for readers
and then the decision will be made from
there right which actually happens
pretty frequently nowadays it's done in
one-off comics it's done in like
one-shots or like elseworld stories or
what-if stories or things that don't tie
into the main continuity so that way if
the story's not well received marvel and
dc can just write it off and just say
well it's not in continuity it doesn't
matter and that's it or if it is well
received they're like well i mean it is
in continuity now and they just roll it
over into the into their main universe
but nonetheless right like realizing
what's going on here there is a kind of
a kind of a note right an addendum
that's made with regards to like this
whole involvement of the network these
individuals that are all just kind of
out there doing their own thing that
somebody had basically sold a cruise
missile to a u.s
supervillain of course this is barbara
gordon putting the pieces together and
referencing the referencing back to the
events of death in the family and the
death of jason todd that this network
has largely been operating behind the
scenes for a long time and the joker
being able to like leave the states and
take off to like the middle east and
then these things involving like jason
todd showing up there and then jason
todd basically being beat to death and
then blown up by all these things are
basically a result of the network being
involved right giving the joker
information giving the joker resources
different things along those lines it's
a huge change to the joker mythos
because over the years in those things
we it always kind of felt like there was
something else going on behind the
scenes but it added to the intrigue and
the mystery of the joker when he would
just go off on these weird things and
somehow attain the ability to travel
internationally and no one really asking
any questions but it was kind of like i
mean how how can the joker get on an
international flight right like one of
the most wanted criminals in the world
how does this guy board an international
flight and leave the us
how does that happen right it's just one
of those things that we as fans found
ourselves asking and it's james tennion
providing a bit of an answer whether or
not you agree with it that's really on
you right i'm curious to see how people
feel about it i don't really care one
way or the other but i think it's cool i
think it's somewhat interesting uh but
the thing about this is that once uh of
course jim gordon and vengeance get into
the the home itself everybody's just
been shot up and then at that point you
basically have the head lab tech now of
course as soon as vengeance sees joker
because of her programming she
immediately goes and tries to attack him
and that's when the the lab tech is just
kind of like orchard hammer obsidian and
those three words shut her down right
just of course again a part of her
mental conditioning but there's this
moment where the joker and the text
start talking to jim gordon and it's one
of those things where where joker's like
you're here for the same reason i am man
you have questions like you want to know
what's going on and this guy is going to
give us the answer now the funny thing
about this is this guy's eyes are given
to us as like green eyes and my initial
thought here is this guy's under the
control of the joker but it doesn't
really look to be that way it looks like
it's that's just who he is right he's
just really creepy looking with green
eyes but he says that like the joker has
won already wired the house to explode
so you probably shouldn't try anything
um and two the lab tech the the head lab
guy is kind of like i mean you should
leave man it's one of those things where
he tells him like what's going on here
between myself and the joker doesn't
involve you i mean he says it
specifically he says like i suggest you
leave now you have your assault rifle
and i presume there's a car out front
you drove up here with take both
vengeance and yourself and leave and he
says like my conversation with the clown
does not concern you your friends in
gotham city or your new friend at
interpol which is kind of a cool thing
because what this means and this is this
is interesting it means he knows
everything that jim gordon's been doing
and i love this idea because it ties
more into the network than anything else
they have eyes and ears everywhere that
everything jim gordon has been doing is
known to the network because there are
people there whether it's some secretary
somewhere or some high-ranking agent in
interpol they basically been reporting
back giving information to the network
as they're supposed to do and it's
allowed them to keep eyes and ears on
what jim gordon is doing and so it's
kind of a funny thing right because the
joker responds he was like freddie i
told you jim gordon was a fast learner
right he's one of us so we don't need
any secrets here now i gotta say every
time i hear the joker or read the joker
talking in dc comics i think of mark
hamill from batman the animation series
who do you think of do you think of like
heath ledger or do you think of mark
hamill like i'm just kind of curious for
my own my own curiosity but in the end
dr friedrich baum of course giving
himself his name to jim gordon says like
he is a member of the network but
honestly he refers to it as just kind of
like a ridiculous name that's created by
police and intelligence agencies because
they don't know how else to define it
the reality here is the network is not
really an organization itself operating
behind the scenes which is to say a
giant council of people who like meet
once a year and they decide how crime's
going to happen in the world it's not
really that way it breaks the tradition
of what we're used to so it's not like
the hellfire club in marvel comics right
it's not like the court of owls and dc
comics it's not like that instead the
way he defines it is he says we are
independent players who work together to
avoid attention of the authorities and
the costume heroes and villains of the
world and so it's just like i mean we
all do our own independent thing but we
pass information to each other but if
what you're expecting out of the network
is that we are somehow some clandestine
shady organization that meets with black
cloaks and tiki torches in some caves
somewhere that's not how this works
that's not what we do and so he's like
you know if you are going to stay here
jim gordon then i might as well do with
you what i did with a clown which is to
show you the laboratory and to show you
everything that i do now this is really
really sadistic and it's really screwed
up but it's kind of cool at the same
time so the way this lab works and what
this guy says is he says my original
proposal was rather simple he says i
grew body doubles for members of the
criminal underworld able to pay my fees
and he says a dna sample some basic
blood work and biometric scans and i'd
be able to tailor one of my slugs to the
target let's say a man was put away in
prison for life i could create a
functional duplicate of the man and give
that duplicate a heart attack or an
aneurysm they'd find the dead body in
that prison cell there was an artistry
to it matching the dental records giving
the body scars making sure the hands and
feet were calloused enough paying off
the guards to swap the dead body with
the alive person and then killing the
guards months later to ensure that no
trail existed and we give our clients
new faces and identities and set them
back out in the world with a whole new
life painstaking work but rewarding now
here's the thing about this and this is
there it gets it gets worse like believe
me it gets worse here but here's the
thing this is pretty genius man i mean
it really really is because you have to
believe that the different villains who
exist out there in the world all have
different desires maybe there's a
villain out there who desires to like
just experience what it's like to be
convicted of murder and then like go to
jail right like they want to know what
it's like to go through all that so they
commit a murder they're arrested by the
cops they go to jail right they go
through like the whole trial and maybe
the the scene is so bloody and so
obviously them that the trial just
happens with a quickness and so they're
thrown in jail and they're like this is
really interesting okay let's get me out
of here and they basically have this guy
create a body double and according to
this guy i mean he was meticulous if
this person had a scar on their kneecap
that they got when they were 10 a scar
was put on the body double and it was
made to look like it had been there
since it was 10 years old everything
matched perfectly and then in turn the
bodies were switched and that was it i
mean this is a level of planning and
strategy that's just astronomical
imagine if like i mean this is batman
level prep time you know what i mean
like it's it's crazy right imagine if a
person like this put their mind to task
in like robbing banks or something like
that i mean obviously his skills are
much better served doing what he's doing
because people are paying you know
absorbent amount of money in order to do
this right just huge amounts of cash but
then he goes on and he says there was
another use for my work that i did not
expect though i did find the project
stimulating and he says there are a
number of very powerful individuals in
the world who have grown fond of the
taste of human meat and so what this guy
did as crazy as it was what he did is he
basically broke down the body's
traditional physical structure and then
what he would do in order to satiate the
appetites of what were basically
cannibals out there in the world it's he
would grow human bodies but instead he
would perfect the balance between fat
i.e marbling and like flesh and so for
those of you guys out there who who are
not really familiar with steak uh like
kobe beef is kind of like the perfect
meat out there you might also hear
referred to as wagyu but like a wagyu
steak will on average cost you about 200
bucks but say for example you wanted to
order like a 20 ounce ribeye that was
basically why you it'll cost you even
more than that it'll cost hundreds of
dollars and the reason why is because
the meat is the perfect balance of like
marbling and and like meat itself right
the perfect balance of like fat and meat
and so it makes it ridiculously tender
and i don't know if it's true or not but
i've heard that like out there in japan
they massage the cows and give them like
the best possible life and all that kind
of stuff that's what was going on here i
mean i don't know if this guy was
massaging these cadavers but the point
behind this is that
that seems pretty grotesque right this
guy just go like it just seems morbid
man like growing these bodies like these
brain dead bodies and like putting them
up on meat hooks and then massaging them
that just i mean it seems like something
he would do
i'm not even gonna lie god that is so
morbid i don't know why i think it's
funny anybody who's been around this
channel long enough knows that like i
have i don't know what it is man but i
laugh at the most inappropriate times
i'm like dr hibbert from the simpsons
i'm imagining this guy massaging corpses
and just being like yes this will make a
fantastic meal i i don't know it's just
it's weird i got problems
i got problems man but uh
[Laughter]
give me a second guys
but uh nonetheless
so the the thing about this right is
like literally that's what he would do
like he said there's like like a dozen
specialty restaurants around the world
with secret menus right just super
high-end restaurants with secret menus
that he supplies these bodies to and
those individuals who are familiar with
this process and are and know about the
secret menus can order flesh now it's
not as though they're going to be
sitting in the table and be like i'd
like a leg of man but that's not really
what they're what they're they're
ordering it's just a particular name
right and it's like okay like we'll
serve this person just human flesh it's
pretty screwed up beyond that though and
it was really more of just like a
personal desire right a personal
interest in understanding all this is
that one as dr baum talks to jim gordon
one of the things he says is my
operations here are never going to come
to light just so you know literally this
guy's like jeffrey epstein right like he
just he's he's in bed with everyone
right politicians princes like members
of the royal family out in england like
everybody somewhere has done business
with this guy and so if he were to end
up in jail and there's the potential
that he would squawk they'd silence him
within hours within hours of him being
arrested he'd be a dead man because he
just knows too much and too many people
would basically see their lives and
reputations completely shattered because
of the revelations this guy could bring
to life and so he's like there's just
too much at risk nothing i'm doing here
is ever going to come to light you take
like if you take what it is that i've
done here and you go to the cops you're
gonna die like somebody out there
somewhere right some fbi agent or some
politician or somebody they're going to
know your name they're going to know
that you know too much you're going to
die before you heard the sound that
killed you that's exactly what's going
to happen and so it's just kind of like
okay like at that point it's really kind
of james tinion telling us this is it
right i mean jim gordon's getting a tour
here but nothing's going to come of this
and so of course the joker kind of
taunts him and says like well you know
it's him trying to get under your skin
whatever but at the end of the day is
this really interesting thing because
they take him to the next stage which is
basically this guy dr bomb has been
trying to clone the joker he's been
trying to create jokers right and in
fact he's actually trying to create five
jokers five different versions of this
guy now what he says here is the process
seemingly cannot be done and the reason
why is because when the joker was
exposed to the chemicals that turned him
into what he is that it basically
altered his genetic his genetic material
which means that he does not have
traditional human genetic material the
only way to duplicate the joker
successfully would be to get a sample of
the joker which seemingly dr bomb has
done but even then it still can't happen
instead what are in these tubes are like
the joker with like two heads right like
just these twisted screwed up grotesque
versions of the joker all of which are
basically laughing and that's when jim
gordon is like good god man like are
they all alive and it's like i mean in a
way i guess you know but like not not
traditionally but it's grotesque man it
is it's so screwed up and that's the
crazy thing is because like jim gordon
immediately points the gun to the joker
and it's just like you're trying to make
more of yourself and the joker's like no
that's the joke jim this is not me i
didn't want this right like they wanted
to do it they wanted to create more of
me and the question that jim gordon of
course asked here is why why would you
want to create more of that guy one is
bad enough why would you want to make
five more and the response to dr baum is
like why does anybody do anything right
the challenge just intrigued me and i
was paid a significant amount of money
to do so and that's when jim asks like
who would want another another one of
him right like who would want and like
who would want more jokers so seemingly
someone is paying dr bomb to try to
create more jokers meaning somebody out
there wants more jokers and it's not
joker himself which really begs the
question who is it right like okay
answer that who do you think is funding
this whole thing right who do you think
is is trying to have more jokers created
and i want your wildest guesses right if
you think it's like the riddler if you
think it's two-face if you think it's
like the court of owls let me know who
you think it is but but before an answer
can really be given here of course
there's like a kind of giant crash that
happens and of course they come to the
conclusion that like essentially
vengeance has woken up and of course
there's a little bit of discussion here
about how great vengeance is it's kind
of like an engineered organism and that
kind of a thing and of course when the
door gets smashed open dr obama is kind
of like okay vengeance kill joker and
jim gordon only for us to find out it's
not vengeance right it's a member of the
sanford family now remember the sanford
family have something to do with the
joker we don't really know what we know
they're like a side plot right but we
don't know exactly what their whole
involvement and their whole role is here
and even now it's a little mysterious
like the only thing this chick says is
uncle sawyer always said that your lab
meat tasted a bit off you can't taste
the fear of death in it makes the meat
sweeter when it's been hunted proper but
i guess we're just a little
old-fashioned down in texas and she says
the way our family sees it we've been
paying dues to your network for a long
long time we think that affords us the
chance to get a little messy y'all
shouldn't have let our uncle billy die
and like that's the only involvement
that we get right like literally there's
you know she's just like okay buddy like
take the joker let's get out of here uh
we're basically gonna feed the joker
like we're gonna eat the joker uh and
then her idea is to kill jim gordon she
literally just stabs him in the chest
and leaves them for dead but like all
these roads are finally coming together
why all these roads are finally
connecting because we didn't really know
what the sanford family had to do with
anything all we knew is that uncle billy
would it was basically this guy who had
been busted for the murder of a whole
bunch of teenagers who he had presumably
consumed he'd been an arkham asylum and
then basically died right he was gas to
death which seemingly happened because
of the joker that seemed to be his
involvement so that seems to be where
those two roads connect the joker's
responsible for the death of billy but
beyond that like we didn't know what
their involvement was obviously they're
tied into the network now if for no
other reason than the fact that that's
where they've been getting their human
flesh from in order to consume but
there's obviously something much bigger
going on here which we'll actually find
out in the next issue or the next video
instead what goes on is you basically
switch over to these last few moments
with jim gordon where he's just kind of
laying there and quite literally he is
he's visited by vengeance who's just
like where in the hell is joker and he's
like the joker went to texas that's all
i really know and so vengeance just
leaves jim gordon there and it's just
like you know uh i'm not gonna save your
life but die knowing that you will have
your vengeance jim gordon and so in
these moments he pulls out his phone he
makes a call to barbara gordon and of
course barbara not realizing that he's
injured immediately starts talking right
immediately starts going through all
this information that she has and she
says like i don't know what it is that's
going on right now but whatever it is
like it's personal and the reason why is
because the talent that's currently
working for the court of owls is
actually james gordon jr the brother of
barbara gordon and the son of jim who we
all thought was death this story is
getting amazing with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace
you